[Music]
no i've never been a fan of facebook as
you probably know i've never been a big
zuckerberg
fan i think he's a real problem uh-huh
they didn't used to like zuckerberg
because they didn't think they could
control them and all the conservatives
meet on facebook and talk about
unauthorized things that was joe biden
last december
very different joe biden now he's not
saying much about facebook he's helping
facebook
of course things have changed a lot
since then biden's transition team has
started hiring top officials and
lobbyists from silicon valley
why well let's see facebook and twitter
and google too
censored stories about hunter biden's
business deals the biden
families business deals with businesses
connected directly to the communist
chinese party
tonight we're learning more though
dozens of executives at facebook
of which body is not a fan and twitter
started spending big on joe biden
in the race for example at facebook the
vice president of public
policy aaron egan donated more than 99
000
to democrats this year including biden
at twitter a senior director of product
management called james kelm donated
more than five grand just to joe biden
and there are many more of course so in
total what are these contributions the
pattern
of money moving from silicon valley into
the coffers of the democratic party and
joe biden
what do they tell us kenneth owens is
one of our all-time favorites we're
happy to have her on tonight to unravel
this mystery so kenneth you look at
these numbers
you look at the behavior of the party
what do you conclude
i conclude that this is the least
shocking story of 2020
for any american that has been paying
attention um
to what we have been seeing this year in
terms of what is really just mass
censorship and here's what's really rich
tucker
do you remember when uh the leftist
media hacks were trying to convince us
that the big evil scary gop plot to
voter suppress
existed in people waiting in line to
vote remember to cast their ballots in
georgia they showed a picture
of a perfectly average line and said
look the gop is
suppressing votes this is a form of
voter suppression and every time you see
something like this a ridiculous story
you know that the job of a really good
media hack is to make sure americans
are looking the wrong way when real
crimes and real issues are actually
peeping up
one such issue is the way that facebook
and twitter virtually intervened
on this election cycle and they did this
quite openly via
fact checkers that popped up out of
nowhere fact checkers that were pulling
down stories
like the hunter biden story suppressing
it saying missing context
we don't have the information joe biden
hasn't confirmed that his son is guilty
therefore
this story is somehow untrue well we
always knew if these fact checkers
weren't checking facts what they were
doing was suppressing information
and that is a form of voter suppression
well of course it is
and of course nothing's being done about
it to this day
but the clarity of the payoff here
i mean even as joe biden is criticizing
facebook
clearly didn't mean it facebook's
employees are sending him
money facebook's owners are working
around the clock to get him
elected spending a lot of hundreds of
millions of dollars
i mean they're basically buying
the biden people
that's exactly right that's exactly
right and the american people know this
and the question is what is going to
actually be done about this
obviously there exists some relationship
uh behind the scenes and they feel
comfortable under a biden
and harris administration and they
didn't have that level of comfort trump
was talking about
revoking their protections under section
230 which they should
by the way i'm not against facebook
having opinion or having a position as
long as they are willing to admit that
they are in fact a publisher
you are a publisher you are pulling down
information that you don't like because
you are a publisher
they should be afforded no protections
under 230 and that's exactly what trump
was trying to do
and i feel that now under a biden harris
administration they will be perfectly
protected
to continue suppressing and censoring
any information that they don't like
i mean can you imagine in 1980 if
general motors and general electric and
ibm got together and said you know we
run this country we're picking the
president this year
i think the media would say something
about it right
you'd think so but the media today this
is not something that people trust
you're seeing this
uh it's really it's broken down they no
longer represent the thoughts and the
opinions of the people they are bought
out by corporations and they are there
to make sure that the corporate
narrative
um is protective they're bought out by
politicians they're there to make sure
that certain politicians are protected
this goes on behind the scenes and the
american people know this and it's
unfortunate that we've seen this in this
regard it feels like it's sped up over
this last year
we've never ever seen this level of
suppression and censorship in america
a praetorian guard for the powerful i
agree completely kennedy's great to see
you tonight
thank you